[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bon moi je suis ici pour explorer une
audace dans le convoi n'a vous
connaissez tous le gondwana ce qu'on a
fait du gondwana candy gondwana les gens
voient le parlement du rire les gens
voient abidjan capitale du rire le
gondwana c'est une manière d'exploser
des frontières avec le parlement du rire
on a tous les humoristes d'afrique qui
vient dans cette émission on a des
togolais des béninois des burkinabè des
maliens des ivoiriens des nigériens des
congolais les deux congo il vient dans
le parlement du raid dont c'est une
manière pour nous d'exploser les
frontières à busan capitale du rire
pareil a besoin capitale du rc on a fait
de ce festival la le rendez vous de tous
les humoristes
bienvenue au gondwana le film que vous
avez sûrement vu tous en france on l'a
vu dans toute l'afrique
on l'a vu donc c'est une manière avec le
gondwana d'exploser les frontières qu'on
dit le gondwana dans la chronique du bon
vin vous me voyez là ce soir avec vous
mais demain matin vous allez m'entendre
grâce à la nouvelle technologie je me
mets dans ma chambre et j'enregistre ma
chronique
les gens pensent que je suis à paris je
suis ici je vois donc c'est grâce à
cette nouvelle technologie là ce qui
fait que les gens pensent que je suis
caché dans le studio là bas à paris les
gens disent ouais tu es là bas tu
critiques l'afrique tu ne fais que
parler de ce qu'il va pas pourquoi tu ne
parle que de ce qui va bien ou quand tu
parle pas de ce qui va bien je dis toi
tu n'as qu'à parler de ce qui va bien
moi je veux parler de ce qui va pas tu
vois je c'est pour ça qu'on a créé le
gondwana notre beau pays le gondwana
tout à l'heure il parlait des échecs nos
gouvernants on n'échoue pas non mais si
tu joues tu vas en prison un tu ne
grandissent pas une élection pour
échouer les prêtres organise une
élection pour la gagne et c'est pour ça
qu'on donne en inventer l'élection
surprise vous connaissez des élections
surprise
un président fondateur appelle
l'opposition puis le 10è vous là les
élections c'était hier j'ai gagné donne
on a inventé au site
oui hier les élections à un tour il ya
les élections à deux tours au gondwana
ont inventé les élections à demi tour
bah oui les élections à 2011 tu vois
c'est tu te lèves tu veux aller voter
plus tard la police qui était dit duval
au back up fait demi-tour en chez toi tu
vois on va voter pour toi c'est ça les
injections à demi tour donc le gondwana
avec cette chronique du gondwana depuis
huit ans que je la fais je commençais le
19 janvier 2009 c'est à dire un jour
avant barack obama tu vois il a fait ces
mandats il n'est pas bien
moi je suis toujours là donc avec cette
chronique du gondwana petit à petit les
gens ont compris que on veut changer
l'afrique on veut changer ce qui ne va
pas
quand on parle de ce qui ne va pas en
fait c'est pour le changer et au début
même à rfi pour aipac l'humour pouvait
transversale humour pour pouvez vous
pouvez parler aux ivoiriens aux maliens
aux nigériens aux congolais en même
temps en 2 minutes 45 secondes et c'est
ce que je fais depuis huit ans et c'est
ce que je fais avec le parlement du rire
c'est ce qu'on fait tous avec cette
famille du gondwana
on a réuni des ivoiriens des congolais
et c'est le panafricanisme dont parlent
les hommes politiques nous on le fait
dans l'humour et donc vous pouvez étonné
de me voir ce soir ici mais exprime gros
naze avec le gondwana on l'a fait avec
le gondwana
on voit encore plus le faire parce que
on veut que les humoristes je sais qu'il
ya beaucoup de d'acteurs économiques
ici on veut que les humoristes cessent
d'être des saltimbanques qu'on appelle
tania le mariage pour faire rire les
gens
tu vois tu viens tu raconte des blagues
on te donne un casier de bière
tout à l'heure il m'a dit on va te
donner un sens du j'ai dit non non c'est
bon tu as donc on est en train avec
gondwana city production c'est une
société de production que j'ai créée ici
en côte d'ivoire c'est une société de
droit ivoirien
c'est avec ça qu'on produit le parlement
du rire c'est avec cette société qu'on
produit abidjan capitale du rire qu'on a
produit le film bienvenue au gondwana et
qu'on va produire des séries qui sont là
en projet et donc on veut
professionnaliser le secteur que les
artistes jouent avec des contrats qu'ils
aient des cachets à chaque fois et qu'on
les respecte puisse vivre de cet art
vous avez ici en côte d'ivoire des
trésors comme michel goût digbeu cravate
qui sont des stars dans toute l'afrique
jusqu'à très récemment et vivait pas de
leur art ça peut paraître étonnant mais
que depuis deux trois ans que vraiment
ils peuvent vivre de ce qu'ils font
partout en afrique il provoque des
émeutes même à paris et c'est ce qu'on
veut on veut que toute la génération
d'humoristes qui vient vivre de son art
[Applaudissements]